antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage
l'émission était de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
et
le vieux piano delà plat le joug console
console études de piano de la place à
des clients dont l'habitude est dedans
ça
hamdi lé dimanche les autres jours ça
sur les planches
dans la mer il se souvient il rêve son
fait mais c'est alors le sens de
courbatures de ma cachette et soudain de
rang tremblante ému en lui je m'arrête
c'était nous tout ce que je retour comme
cette musique jali mes pauvres ou me
fait du mal
me fait du bien l'ancêtre adieu vieux
piano bonsoir bienvenue au bar de la
plage avec confidences sur ses vacances
et le secret de son obésité
adieu jolie candy de leur tour le père
de marius tenait un bistrot sur le port
toute une histoire
la plage à la page andré bercoff ivres
de livres
les aventures de lolo chez les blaireaux
du bord de l'eau très chaud pour les
petits marie le vrac show de marine et
le barman qui ne l'ouvrent qu'à bon
escient
[Musique]
colonial
je
[Musique]
et
bonjour
[Musique]
oh non
comment tu
mon témoin
une crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
là
non
philo ce n'est qu'au royaume
bologna
[Musique]
tu es
et même choquant non comptés
holmes
ce soir gagner télé book filix répondait
en tapant 36,15 skoda 2 à la question
suivante
de qui jean françois michael at il été
le chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir monsieur bonsoir le poids des
voussoirs j'ai pas vous avez une carte
oui monsieur mais je n'ai pas d'humour
benjamines nous avons de tout sauf de
l'humour je viens de vous le dire
le thonier peut-être un peu trop
alcoolisé pour le début de la soirée
sardou
je conseillerais pas à monsieur si vous
on croyait mon intuition le carlo je
vous préviens monsieur je ne sers qu'en
grande taille
combien j'ai soif vous le voulez
exotiques pathétique nous haïssent les
trois pays les concours à la baule en
1937 avec ce monsieur
s'ils refusent et moi tu passer des
vacances ou quand tu étais petit à côté
d'ici avant d'aboutir à antibes c'est
mon père était venu de russie voulait
retrouver un peu l'ambiance de la ville
un crime est un crime et oui c'est la
merde quoi saisir pool house là où il a
été gorbatchev mis nos talents variés
deux jours certes au bout de la crimée
et ça correspondait un grand climat
d'ici ou d'anti bretonnismes et il a
cherché c'est mon père est un mec
fabuleux système par région je pleurais
peut être est ce un mec qui est arrivé
de prix mais il a su chi parterre était
habile à lui de jeunes officiers avaient
19 heures son père et sa mère rien dit
on le voit plus jamais à temps parce que
c'est plus possible les rouges vont
arriver et il est il éthique le chien à
constantinople en six mois et à trouver
un bateau qui l'a mené à gafsa en
musique était un département français
les bleus et il donne en france et il a
eut rencontré ma mère en 1942 par jean
rostand
tu t'es un mec formidable avec qui j'ai
passé des là j'ai rencontré jean jean
rostand
j'ai passé par exemple 10 heures avec
l'urgent laboratoire où il y avait 2500
beau coq des tritons et du royaume et on
allait chercher ensemble des grands
musées triton à l'aise dans l'est dans
les étangs est temps que je n'avais pas
compris si vous voulez me dire c'est lui
qui était un conte un génie comme jean
restanques un avis sur tout et ça c'est
magnifique quand à 8 ans et que tu vois
un mec comme ça qui a des cheveux blancs
qui prend le temps d'expliquer jusqu'à
acheter compris et c'est là où j'ai
compris que la connerie humaine n'a pas
de limites et qu' il faut de change dix
mois lorsqu'il est très drôle dans cette
histoire c'est que ton père a acheté
antibes en viager la maison des barons
de ville d'avray que ses parents étaient
malades que ton père est devenu
son toubib et s'est occupé de lui et
qu'il l'a tellement bien soigné c'est
que il a vécu ce sera justement le vieux
monde est assez drôle de viager parce
qu'il a quand même duré jusqu'à 100 ans
presque oui mon père un tour et j'ai pas
d'argent mais regagner un peu de pognon
on fera jamais gagner mais ma mère n'a
jamais su je montais regrette lui ai
jamais dit et laissait jamais jusqu'à sa
mort et puis c'était avec sa venue des
pensées ruse merde j'ai pensé tout ce
qu'on sait pas comment un mai et avaient
envie de retrouver sa son pays et quand
il est arrivé à antibes il a trouvé
cette maison en viager que le baron de
ville d'avray que le rendu de la
réveille 77 ans sabri 75 ans est é la
politesse de vos reer deux ans après que
nous raconte les histoires de résister
magnifique c'était chanteuse à gabor de
raconter les histoires l'accent hongrois
et lui ne voulais que mon père médecin
veut il avait 77 ans on a vécu pendant
20 ans dans la cave de notre maison
reçoit dix ont acheté un gramme de baron
avait tout le reste
quel merveilleux baron bailleur lui en
veux pas parce que mon père est de 125
il avait vu ses 90 ans était humide
c'était son vous avez passé 22 ans la
cua willows déjà vu mieux on faisait
merveilleux l'endroit à tes souvenirs de
vacances de l'époque c'est la pêche avec
ton père tu partais à 5 heures du matin
aux trois heures et puis c'est quand
l'ibère cap d'antibes à l'époque c'est à
dire c'était pas comme maintenant il y
avait je pouvais te raconter ce qui se
passait a ajouté paul hévin curé le pur
et dur à l'époque dorée sur l'église et
qui laissait 100 ou 200 mecs dormir en
l'église et que celle de couture ont
décernés tous germain des prés
brutalement il y avait claude lutter
sidney bechet
après les festivals d'audience s'est
passé c'était magnifique sur la plage la
tâche des pirates à juan les pins
on finissait avec la contrebasse j'ai vu
un jour dizzy gillespie jouer assis dans
une boue et de la trompette qu'on ne
sommes pas insister sur le menton temps
d'expliquer aujourd'hui je connais ce
existe pas
ici jeudi c'était avant sa troupe est
avant de bardos la nounou et jean les
pins et devant la station car face à
jack bauer et benneteau dont c'était
cette époque un jour ton père part à la
pêche s'était schouppe a tenu une
dizaine d'années par la pêche tout de
suit en vélo sur les remparts et tu
tombes et comment tu sais ça je sais
tout mais c'est une histoire
extraordinaire parce que tu tombes est
très jeune
tu t'es tellement amoureux de monterrey
c'est en fait c'est mon père qui m'a
dirigé ma vie c'est pas ma mère du monde
croit on demande sur quel pied danser
alto
ma mère a toujours dit que j'ai avec ses
enfants n'étaient pas si 15 humains est
ce que mon père je dirigeais ma vie et
je l'aimé je sais que boris et il
méritait un style isa pas ils devaient 5
heures du matin - 6 heures je fonce au
port je m'étais pas réveillée et puis
revenant je me casse la gueule
un jour les remparts d'antibes et je
tombe de 6,7 mètres de haut et j'ai vu
une chose sais pas si tu l'as vu déjà
toi hein c'est ce qu'on raconte des
choses de la vie
le film devrait sac un étonnant c'est
que jamais non jamais et je te jure je
m'éternise je suis tombé la tête en
avant des remparts d'antibes en vélo
comme un amoureux et j'ai vu le jour ce
magnifique dire que tu vois les plus
beaux moments et asie comme un film en
couleur tu vas mourir j'ai réussi à
savoir pourquoi je disais sportif à
l'époque à retomber sur les gens me suis
cassé les deux jambes mais j'ai vu ma
vie en couleurs
et j'aurais voulu mourir et je suis
tombé dans les bras d'un pote à moi qui
étais pompiers auxiliaires de 17 ans qui
m'a ramené j'ai vu ce pote à mourir
devant moi un an après en plongée
beaucoup de choses qui sont et quelques
elle sait qu'elle tu as gardé de cette
2ème jour là c'est devenu gros oui j'y
vois aussi je suis aucune idée je sais
pas si c'est granulaire psychosomatiques
du pain et je veux du yoga j'étais
jamais disant ouais mais bon ça m'a aidé
leur avis parce qu'après j'étais
haltérophiles j'étais d'une aucun gène
les ceintures noires à 14 ans mais
j'avais 10 ans et j'ai grossi inventeur
un grossiste 10 degrés ce temps que
j'étais vraiment heureux
[Musique]
carrément what u fait les choses
toujours comme ça non oui ce vous avez
la sympathie bonjour bonjour ça va bien
tout à fait comment
sur marie oui je suis de nouveau ni oui
ni les tue en vacances lui je suis
arrivé hier je fais toute la côte
tu viens de voir
ao je suis bien entouré gardes du corps
c'est ce lien entre open
et tu t'es là pour combien de temps tu
sais pas tu la prends des français tu
parles déjà bien français on sent bien
ouais le bel oiseau hockey ce week end
là moi qu'est ce que c'est peu dire en a
pas grand chose
dis-moi comment tu nous tiens tu sais
déjà comment tu me saoul moi je te
confirme que ouais non
en fait
les matheux fait un jogging j'essaye
j'ai nagé un cours de sport
non je crois que fleur l'amour c'est pas
mal non plus comme sport ça dépend
comment vous à pratiquer est-ce que
états unis si un sport ici je sais pas
les français quand vous trouvez ça
fossilisation proposé mais vous vous
êtes 2 il pas voir un jaloux nos
problèmes à trois podiums comme ça y'a
pas de jaloux waouh
arrête et des yeux et où je pourrai
dormir et tu veux c'est où le plus
romantique pour motif
j'avais déjà fait l'amour adjoint non
merci
si on n'essaie rien dans l'avion n'a pas
tu as raison c'est aussi la politique
c'est magnifique tu veux me dévoile des
yeux ou je sens que ça va être le
paradis ce soir tu en france tu me lis
langue française fait encore un visio
d'un coup avec new kiss me
[Musique]
ils ont carlos est vrai que quand tu
étais petit antil tu mettais un masque
et puis tu te mettais la hauteur de
l'eau comme ça avec la moitié au dessus
et la moitié ou dessous et puis tu te
demander dans quelle dans quel univers
si vous voulez vivre si tu voulais vivre
au dessus du lot en dessous de l'oreille
je veux mon masque de bûches ou mariné
au masque un petit journal et je voyais
un petit peu de la vie et robbie c'est à
dire des gens qui vivaient sur la met
sur les routes est pas tous les
immeubles qu'ils disaient et je voyais
aussi le monde sous marin
je me suis dit c'est là c'est l'actuelle
saison je me vide et fait du bien j'ai
découvert ce site que l'eau c'était
vraiment un élément et du poisson vrai
et d'ailleurs toi avec le poids que tu
fais faut bien dire que dans l'eau c'est
mieux pour toi moi aussi j'en attends qu
il serait temps d'expliquer partout dans
le monde des clubs la flotte je me donne
un couac quelle que soit la mer général
et la mer personne ne le sait ça ce
liquide amniotique c'est exactement le
même
on est content de la vente d'un moment
c'est un côté dolto ça la mère et la
mère sur la mer et me et re on sait pas
comment ça fonctionne mais je te jure
que quand je suis dans l'eau quand il se
dit comme c'est bien je te retrouves
dans le vent de tout moment dis-moi tu
as peur c'est beau hein tu t'appelles
yvan chrisostome ce que ça veut dire
chrisostome oui chrysostomos soyaux
bouche de voix la bassée bouche d'or
carlo
[Musique]
voilà plus d'une robe en quarts elle
affrontera louise justement du mois
alors comme à l'habitude mais reste ou
pas tu sais me rassure mais jusqu'au
moment où j'allais vers la cabine tu
rigoles
j'ai passé là
koné
tarifs
[Musique]
là ça va pas la bâche mais pourquoi nous
dit rien la [ __ ] à la machette et
raide comme un chien mais ton coeur
d'être au top mais tu préfères la tombe
mal café d'en face comme un des shows
comme un con mais en fait au moment où
ton café sont 29 juin à voile ou par la
scission et mobile est pas tout à fait
celui que tu t'en doutes est celle qui
se fait déjà parti avec lui
j'aime pas massive
le cas isabelle
j'avais quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
devant le bar qu'elle préfère le chant
venu arrivée l'éditeur dc vigueur
qu'elle jugerait qatar envoie plusieurs
qui rigole qui séparent bordeaux qui se
foutent de symbole
ridicule qui demande à l'aplomb de
serveuse qui lui avait ravi pour ne
sépare nul pourquoi le comment déclare
innocent je sais très bien que tout
[Musique]
j'étais encore démenti
zabel
moi j'ai pas dessus pas connu enfin
j'aime avec si près mais je n'étais plus
rien maintenant c'est pour de vrai
maintenant
présents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui est là qui quand il était petit
avant qu'il ne s'endorme je raconte est
toujours la même histoire à mon fils de
la cl zaki non monsieur
pourquoi monter vous
enfin monsieur je ne manque pas se
raconte des histoires
[Musique]
alors marines palmyre bonsoir alors tu
as toujours travailler au noir toi un
petit peu au lin j'ai toujours fait un
peu ce que j'ai voulu c'est un
indépendant quoi j'étais un peu comme
les oiseaux qui nous coûtent pas sur le
courage a été danseur dont était dans
son mandat c'est à dire j'ai eu des
propositions pour monter à paris pour
lancer
j'ai eu des propositions c'est qu'à
saint tropez rencontre toutes sortes de
gens
et dieu sait si j'en ai connu boxer ou
de le présenter aussi un vrai outil est
champion du monde après pour chanter il
ya un gars nîmes qui voulait me
présenter à l'imprésario à marseille moi
j'ai jamais rien de plus au sérieux quoi
c'était fou chaleur torride qualité
jamais été footballeur cgt fo de valeur
juste que tu es sur tous ces champions
de vous le provençal et où ils
s'asseyent quémanda d'après match et
qu'on un siège aux bulls est spécialisé
dans les pouilles
j'ai gagné au moins 3,5 concours jeux
partout au départ on tenait un bal saper
le balte à venir
c'était aussi la citadelle tropez et
c'est vrai qu'à mistinguett maurice
chevalier qu'ils sont produits en
enlevant les manques faire et elle qui
lâche cette affaire loin ce qu'on fait
un joli et été je crois qu'ils devraient
faire une balle mais avec quoi quelle
honte quelle époque et alors il a
commencé à dégager la piste
et puis la clôture et ouais elle écrit à
sa cage à poules et après par la suite
mistinguett avait baptisé sa la cage à
poule parce que la remontée n'a pris
encore un cadeau non je vais les pays
maghrébins
c'est devenu fois maintenant alors le
bal pamiers c'est dommage si vous n'êtes
pas de continuer ce que nous faisions
nous parce que nous à l'époque on aurait
tapé sur des casseroles que les gens
venaient ouais parce qu'il y avait
l'ambition il y avait des comics intel
et toutes sortes d'individus y avait des
voyous il y avait des gens bien il est
tout ce qu on voulait surtout démarrage
mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait une
américaine qui adorait danser avec toi
alors qu'il voulait amener à cincy
natixis de 7 et une femme qui mange qui
très jeune j'ai même pas ce que c'est
les fans un jeu plage d'ansé je n'y
arrivais à séné et
j'avais à las vegas pour moi elle avait
demandé un des parents par tarik el
hassen cinat épouvanté pas partie
j'étais jeune puis moins par montréal et
ses montants autorisés
ouais mais c'est vrai qu'un jour il ya
un homosexuel qui a voulu t'acheter un
abri dans cette histoire c'est à dire je
plaisais beaucoup à ces messieurs
ouais d'affaires moi j'étais de l'autre
côté et celui ci aussi voulait m'emmener
en amérique
ah bon à tout prix alors été embrassée
sur la bouche
ah non mais ça c'est un autre cette
monoplace un bon c'est un jeune elle
était tellement sympa je suis j'avais le
plateau dans les mains comme si un
détenu par derrière
on visitera à l'addition pourrait être
celui-là salé l'addition
voilà c'était sympa ouais c'est vrai
qu'il ya une soixantaine d'années saint
tropez c'était un petit chicago et que
ouais qu'est ce qui se passait à saint
tropez il se passe c'est que d'abord
c'était un port marchand et avec moins
gentil de gens tu sors d'une nationalité
quoi est elle est surtout des bagarres
des bagarres alors ils finissent mal
il n'y avait pas de lien pas de police
la santé par un sentier pas parce qu'ils
avaient le trac est ce que c'est et puis
c'était des hommes qui étaient très
costauds très méchant est ensuite très
couvrir bus aurait pris une bouteille je
ne me tanne arriver là mais vous allez
c'était comme ça n'hésitez pas d'erreur
c'est ton père était obligé de sortir le
nerf de boeuf ont fait un ctp c'est une
affaire très difficile à tenir
il y avait les voyous là c'était moment
et des méchants c'est vrai quoi mme
lagarde a gagné un peu d'argent fin de
ce fait j'ai fait ce que vous conseillez
a que des noirs ne sont des quoi le
déficit us et c'est à dire je dépannais
plutôt les gens que je ne connais pas
tellement pour l'argent on doit demander
des cartes de pain on a demandé il ya
les troupes américaines que le débarquer
alors là il y avait de la marchandise y
en a mais on peut tous y avait de tout
retournement des ca par camion 1 ce qui
avait de la place pour gary et par
camion n'a pas été résistant non mais
j'ai fait des trucs au débarquement que
les résistances aux dix ans je les
voyais tous plantés sous les ponts parce
qu'ils avaient peur et moi j'étais par
tous genres à bastille et les
mitraillettes venait de tomber du ciel
et j'ai failli me faire tuer moi
j'appelle cela qui va souvent la pêche
c'est à dire là c'est autre chose le
bateau stupide histoire
ça a été le 40% de malice les bateaux ça
a été j'ai fait des rencontres la
sensationnelle
si je vous disais les gens que j'ai eu à
bord mais moi je n'ai pas eu un livre de
bord j'ai eu
et tous les bras droit de de gaulle va
qu'avis grands décorateurs partie cinéma
pour les mines et victor madeleine
renaud jean louis barrault
la marseillaise benzema l'homme de fer
les gagner comment s'appelle le monde et
demandent de charleroi est ainsi très
des centaines d'errol flynn
non non et re fignon abord rôles fine
c'est le premier qui m'a pris une photo
en couleur à palabres au début des
appareils qu'elle était sortie déjà les
footballeurs il venait avec son bateau
les ak oui un tag avec son équipage de
noir c'est un beau bateau qui a vraiment
découvert synphot petacchi était là dès
le départ c'est à dire sans trophée mes
parents en larmes quand cette affaire
toute la jeunesse de saint tropez appelé
les gens de mon âge on tous appris à
danser
c'était déjà et puis c'était très côté
raconté il y avait pincé savons guère ça
me début j'étais tout chez nous c'était
un peu qu'ils ont un peu quand on parle
de lui il ya toujours eu
peu de monde des gens très bien et
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que tu penses de
ce qui est devenu son propre et autre
chose autre chose ce qu'ont fait ou
tracassés 1
avant les gens voyez les gens bien aimé
par exemple pour côtoyer les gens du
pays ouais manger chez eux qu bon c'est
manger chez vous par plaisir parce que
c'est le chant qui on avait des cadillac
ou alors on est ramené les foyers
demandé de les conduire à l'autel vous
avez un petit peu éméché et vivons
reviendrait à la cadillac chez vous rien
ne peut leur le soupe de poisson année
charge main on était bien servir
il ya des gens comme ça le joli c'est
fini tout ça
non non c'est peut-être pas fini parce
que dans la poule à il ya peut-être
encore des gens comme ça c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de les trouver et le
temps d'autres pas qu'il pleut beaucoup
quand même en ce moment vient au mois
qu'on attend la pluie prince aussi faut
s'attendre ce soir
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu vas imaginer là
maintenant ma chérie mais puisque je te
dis que c'est l'infirmière de gilbert je
les ai commandé ce matin en sortant qui
les aura demain soir en rentrant je
t'aime
vous n'avez pas de femme jacqueline non
monsieur bah alors une femme soit
s'entretient sinon adieu jolie candy
monsieur
[Musique]
adieu jolie famille
tu as
[Musique]
à
chic
une boîte à pain
[Musique]
de jamais
on allait
non
c'est à dire
mais qui dit
[Musique]
adieu jolie candy
plume écrira
je le dis
mais l'ombre
ça
[Musique]
je reprends
comme ça
et effet de penser
[Rires]
ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un vieux chien
nous
[Musique]
lui
m
et
[Musique]
alors jean françois michaël bonsoir
bonsoir
alors adieu jolie candy c'était en
quelle année 1968 dis moi qui est écrit
l'adieu jolie pendu jeudi qu en dise
c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle raymond
janot il ya l'autre s'appelle franck à
revel qui est alain boublil qui est
grave
la révolution française qui on doit
aussi les misérables
ça s'est vendu à combien de 2 millions
d'exemplaires je suis incapable de vous
dire parce que je l'enregistrais dans
cinq ou six langues
à mon avis on a dû avoisiner les 3 4 ou
5 mois mais quand même
oui je suis parti en italie en espagne
en allemagne au japon
j'ai fait le tour du monde c'est à
rapporter combien toi récemment rapporté
d'abord lé aston martin de que j'ai
absolument voulu acheter donc de cotiser
de goldfinger
ouais une petite rolls et puis ça m'a
rapporté le fait d'être très très
heureux pendant des années à des cadeaux
aux amis tu mets mon métier tu as dit je
suis passé du solex à la rolls oui tout
à fait sûr que nos solex jeu tu as
commencé très jeune enfant à l'âge de 9
ans à l'âge de 9 ans tut tut tut et à
l'alhambra déjà à l'alhambra sur les
genoux de matéri et je vendais les
pastilles valda c'est-à-dire à dire je
devais faire
manas est bon a commencé jeune oui oui
et je me cachais dans la langue bras
parce que je voulais toujours assister
au concert de zizi jeanmaire de pauline
de roland petit est alors à 18 ans tu
étais le chauffeur de barbara donc tu
avais vraiment envie de réussir dans le
chalet je vais raconter non j'étais
chauffeur de barbara parce que ma soeur
son équipe à l'époque est alors j'étais
le chauffeur mais le plus mauvais
chauffeur et un jour avec barrage et
l'anecdote on était à orly elle arrivait
barbara eu un malaise elle est tombée
par terre je n'ai pas relevé j'ai pas
aussi tu as commencé par faire trois
disques raté sous le nom de yves rooses
force et la bossa nova
ouais ça marchait pas du tout a pas du
tout ça intéresse pas du tout et puis un
jour un directeur artistique et a
conseillé de changer de nom comment ça
s'est passé et non j'ai choisi un nom
ouais le plus plus beau en consonance ça
m'a pris la nuit
jean françois michaël faut dire que le
risque d'être très à la mode des prénoms
et puis on pensait pas du tout que ça
marcherait et c'est au mois de juillet
on a commencé à m'appeler en disant tu
sais que tu vends beaucoup tu
j'ai dit c'est formidable ça va me poser
quelques problèmes à la rentrée quand
même quand je vais revenir travailler
dans la maison ouais bah oui parce qu'à
l'époque j'avais en mettant wight is
wight avec michel delpech ou et fêter le
producteur le directeur artistique
à l'époque j'étais directeur artistique
j'ai des monnaies travail donc chez
barclay et c'était très embêtant d'être
tous les deux numéros 1 sans que l'on
sache qui était l'autre mais tu t'es
arrêté pourquoi enfin j'ai au bout de
cinq ans et j'en avais vraiment à qui
vous alors ça marche et nord celle d'il
ya deux écoles y en a qui disent que en
fait il s'est arrêté parce que ça
marchait pas ouais moi je le dirai pas
parce que je le crois pas c'est un peu
vrai et puis et puis en fait c'est pas
pour ça c'est parce que ça me plaisait
plus ouais non plus du tout est ce qu'il
ya un côté qui est déplaisant c'est que
les gens te reconnaissent partout tu
peux pas vivre normalement
une fois que tu l'as vécu très fort
c'est bien le vivre une fois et après il
faut retourner un peu l'anonymat ah bon
ça t'embête est vraiment qu'on vient de
demander des autographes que ça n'ait
pas trouvé des plages déclare yves au
restaurant à ça c'est pas très gênant
way trouver des places dans les avions à
faire c'est pas gênant ce qui est gênant
c'est après d'être conscient finalement
2-2 les gens te reconnaissent mais en
fait ils reconnaissent pas pour ce que
tu es c'est embêtant quand on a d'autres
choses à dire et dont je vous a fait
alors après les problèmes ont commencé
parce que tu as fait la prison un moment
non oui mais c'est quoi l'histoire
l'histoire si je me remets une société
qui était que ça ps et mr après tout à
fait mais je m'en rappelle plus
quantifiable et dire que tu avais
emprunter 100 mille francs à quelqu'un a
bien deux pour monter une société a
doctor tout à fait état jamais monté la
société asi la société a été montée mais
le papier du greffe a été perdu voilà et
tu as fait 34 jours de prison tout à
fait c'est dur j'ai revu encore qu'une
journée avant
oui parce que je recevais des je
recevais des convocations et je n'y
allais pas un jour donc la convocation
est arrivé je suis pas allé et je
voulais pas dire où je t'aime ce que je
voulais pas métro
les gens quittent avec moi n'est venu me
chercher pour m comme ces mois de
juillet vous y rester et puis quand le
juge est déjà arrivé le premier au mois
d'août et d'impartition de ses sorties
le journal et quand tu étais en prison
tu regrettait pas quand même d'avoir un
petit peu méprisé là le fait d'être star
et le fait d'être reconnu par tout ça
ils ont retenu
incroyable non reconnu après tu étais
malade
oui j'étais malade on s'est foutu fumait
beaucoup de cigarettes oui je continue
je vais mais deux trois paquets par jour
et a eu un cancer de la gorge ou un
départ oui mais si t'as pas arrêter de
fumer
non tu a divorcé à cette époque si oui
c'est de la négo le même oui oui oui
c'est pareil c'est pas dit non c'est non
c'est pas beaucoup c'est la vie t'as pas
plus flipper que ça qui certainement
mais je m'en rappelle pas tu veux pas
tant la paix non c'est pas que je veux
pas me rappeler c'est que c'est il ya eu
tellement de belles choses que
finalement non et comment tu te n'est
sorti de cette époque c'est-à-dire
cancer prison séparation de ta femme
plafond la musique manger toujours
qu'avec à me dis qu'on peut toujours
tout faire alors après justement ça a
très bien marché aux producteurs
wikia produits stéphanie de monaco à
belle aventure de stefanie j'espère
rencontrer comment cet état me voici au
départ bon j'avais une chanson qui
s'appelait ouragans ouais
et puis les gens bizarres à ça c'est
pour ces familles de la course et ça et
pourquoi pas pour le pape
évidemment c'était impossible et puis
j'ai eu la chance de la rencontrer on
s'est rencontré un jour on a parlé tous
les deux je le dis si tu veux tu viens
faire un essai ce soir à l'époque j'ai
pu déjà le pôle études j'avais une fiat
500 jeudi d'écouté je passe vous
prendriez vous et puis je vous emmène et
puis bon j'allais dans un studio qui
s'appelle sur marcadet et donc sur la
porte de la chapelle puis je dis vous
suivez et puis j'étais tellement
nombreux nuages que finalement je suis
arrivé la bretelle de beauvais et il
suivait toujours alors que ses dépens de
la chapelle crise de nerfs et ofi am en
est revenue en arrière elle s'est mis à
chanter et on s'est plus quittés pendant
deux ans sacré champion véritable sais
tu le dis là ce soir c'est est elle bien
sûr c'était souvent la victoire est à
dire que pour ouragan il ya eu des
choristes qui ont chanté avec elle le
refrain elle a chanté les couplets mais
dans tout l'album c
c'est une vraie et comment tu expliques
après quelques morceaux d'entrée très
bien marché d'un seul coup et se soit
complètement écroulé au niveau showbiz
s'est pas écoulé on s'est quittés par
amour
c'est à dire qu'il est tombé amoureux de
quelqu'un et qu'elle a préféré choisir
sa vie ce qu'elle cherche toujours
elle cherchait elle a trouvé l'amour et
elle a arrêté la musique
maintenant qu'est ce que tu fais
toujours commencé à chanter ouais nan
parce que tu sors un disque à la rentrée
la des chansons nous servent à des
sorties que j'ai sorti j'ai refait
toutes mes anciennes chansons parce que
je me suis aperçu que conseil faisait 25
ans que je cachais dans un petit coin de
mon coeur le chanteur il existe quand
même le monde a envie comme peut l'être
un peu qu'on le reconnaisse a comme un
petit peu doit revivre un peu tard
commence
oui ça recommence c'est normal parce que
sinon je vais au projeter tout ce que
j'ai de mauvaises sur les gens je vais
produire demain non comme je vais être
de nouveau très équilibré à l'époque
donc quand ça a très bien marché et
ensuite moins bien marché comment tu as
vécu ce changement de situation comment
tuer je vais passer de l'un à l'autre
à l'époque bon c'est vrai il ya un
moment où c'est très difficile très
difficile parce qu'on on regarde autour
si on nous reconnaît encore et puis
finalement on s'aperçoit du tout alors
on se dit que finalement donné plus
grand chose et puis c'est ça qui est
très très dur est à venir
tu as quel âge 45 ans tout va bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
18 25 par deux ça fait 36 50 monsieur
alain ses bibis par 2 1 ah si je vous
dis regardez ça fait 18 francs 25
vous êtes touristes les vacanciers les
prix multiplié par deux les étrangers
par trois arrêts pas vous n'êtes pas
étranger non non non c'est simplement
par deux donc de 18 ans à 5
on passe à 36 50 sont la somme les
touristes et les étrangers maintenant on
le dit c'est nouveau ces nouveaux qu'on
le dise ah ouais mais maintenant moi
j'ai décidé de le dire parce qu on le
fait sans le dire je trouve pas ça aux
nets signés d'être honnête avec les gens
pour la somme 1 c'est vrai qu'on les
vols ou au moins leur dis maintenant
c'est plus régulier ou pensez pas plus à
tout le temps madame tout le temps c'est
depuis depuis que la côte d'azur du
succès on vous vole on a trois mois pour
vous voler c'est pas évident parce que
là l'hiver vous venez pas vous ici on
n'a que trois mois pour vous voulez
encore le mois de juin est pas facile
hein
donc on a vraiment juillet août pour
vous tirer un maximum de pognon quoi des
convois des blaireaux comme vous hop on
les presse comme des citrons coin c'est
marrant de 342 fond monsieur 114 x 3
parce que vous êtes touristes
j'ai de quoi vous êtes suisse allemand
les prix vont regarder monsieur les prix
sont multipliés par deux pour les
vacanciers par trois pour les étrangers
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est en saison on
assène de touristes ici monsieur on a
trois mois pour faire de l'argent
vous le savez bien tout le monde le sait
où on le marque donc ça fait 340 de
francs vous allez bien vous êtes volet
sur la côte d'azur monsieur vous le
savez bien
monsieur nahmad bonjour thomas marivaux
méthode doit bien profond et vous sentez
après quoi les vannes de maraîchers
affligeant ici on pèse ici on assomme
parce que 90
haïti et oui ça fait trente francs vous
êtes tellement s'est multiplié par trois
pour les fridolins regardez c'est du vol
c'est de l'anti ballon les en cubes dont
les en cubes
les étrangers nous entuber entuber le
tweet tweet la claque en tube on le
remet dans le cucquois là ok on va la
refaire
on va la refaire traite à savonner watts
non non non ice tauliaut et aux monnaies
mouais et cosy côte d'azur et ses côtés
juha blaireau blaireau said les
touristes au match au motorola aux mods
on vous aviez [ __ ] et on vous remercie
bien sûr si les prix vous seriez
allemand c'était trois fois le prix non
134 me sied pas cent balles
et vous ça vous est arrivé quand
on vous a bien d'en tuer c'est pas du
tout au moins cher le sex symbol des 400
et défis plutôt des garçons d'ailleurs
dédicacé nos amis les quais rsf
i'm sexy
[Musique]
tu sais que tu es tu sais pas
le
kapo
[Musique]
on a quatre ans
peut-on dire que vous êtes un barman
cultiver jeu dépend à qui on a bon si je
vous disais que c'était un bar cultivé
il faudra immédiatement le prouver en
vous parlant des niveaux des pièces de
théâtre que j'ai vu quelqu'un vous
auriez tôt fait de trouver un autre bar
man avec de l'humour un culte et qui
vous écouterai par les pluies
to be or not to bien monsieur telle est
la question et oui c'est vrai lire ou ne
pas lire les prochains ex p et en fait
tu sais tirer quelque chose qui m'a
toujours frappé c'est que qu'est ce
qu'on s'est fait chier à lire l'histoire
on adore les sur l'année mais tu te
rappelles le néo desclaux pâtre dans la
vessie de crowd mais voilà la face du
monde chargé et nos ancêtres les gaulois
qui avaient tous les cheveux basané et
les yeux noirs de braise et c est tout
droit et en fait moi j'adore l'histoire
et je me suis tu sais jamais vraiment je
souffrais en me disant je dois apprendre
tout ça par coeur et qu'un 115
marinières et c est bien
et quelqu'un qui va donner un formidable
une formidable découverte c'est jean
michel ribes
jean michel ribes dramaturge en claquant
le palace était bourré d'humour et il a
décidé de faire un bouquin qui s'appelle
à j'ai encore oublié sa rue d'ailleurs
il a eu raison
eh bien il a fait toute l'histoire de
france évidemment loufoque complètement
retourné comme un gant et elle a enfin
on peut le lire et on se marre de bout
en bout
maintenant on va passer à autre chose
aussi autre chose que j'ai vu que je
vous conseille de lire et de relire
c'est un taux de lourdes alors autant le
bon ben je vais pas choisir un livre
puis on a tous lu de blondin monsieur
jadis un singe en hiver
et puis c'est merveilleux livre qui
finit par un jour nous prendrons les
trains qui partent
je ne connaissais pas le tgb encore et
tu sais que c'est lui qui aussi a ni
comment faire pour que entre deux trains
les rails ne viennent pas paresseuse une
question métaphysique importante et
cochon vous demande tous chers
téléspectateurs se soumettre à votre
attention
blondin à effet aussi à la table ronde
toujours la table ronde les quatre
saisons
les petites nouvelles automne et hiver
printemps et c'est toujours un délice
parce que c'était un grand enfant que
c'était un grand écrivain et qu'il avait
gardé vraiment une espèce de fraîcheur
non seulement devant la vie mais devant
les mots et vous savez que c'est un des
grands écrivains sportifs
il écrivait dans l'équipe et je
rappellerai que cette anecdote immortel
que au tour de france à chaque étape
tous ensemble le premier soir on leur
sert du stack de pintade le second soir
de la soupe de pintade troisième soit du
ragoût de pintade et enfin look après le
soir de l'ess de pintade à ce moment-là
blondin soleil avait dégoté c'est la
pintade doit faire le tour de france
qu'on lui donne un dossard ça c'était
blondin et blondin est mort par l'alcool
vive l'alcool et vive blondin
et d'aller à fès oui on va à tanger et
on va à tanger avec quelqu'un qui
justement nous montre que la française
c'est d'une patrie internationale pour
tout le monde c'est tahar ben jelloun
mais que les marocains écrivains
français et dont le premier livre
arruda paru d'abord en 1973 vient d'être
réédité à futuropolis avec de superbes
dessins de baudouin vraiment superbe et
c'est une idée de la collection
futuropolis de reprendre des grands
auteurs et avec des dessins céline avec
tardi sollers avec martin veyron et donc
ben jelloun arruda et arruda c'est à la
fois la femme et la ville la femme
imagine ce petit enfant
le tabou du sexe et c'est en terre
d'orient c'est très très très fort est
en même temps une sensualité
extraordinaire la chaleur les voiles
tout ça est il y a une vieille [ __ ] qui
était dans une espèce de crottes et ses
enfants aller la voir et temps en temps
leur montrer le sexe pour quelques sous
pour quelques billes et ça fait penser
raisonnablement à fellini un fellini
marocain et il raconte la [ __ ] la ville
la légende les touareg la fantasia et
tout ça dans cette espèce de sable blanc
de moiteur est vraiment benjelloun
arrive que les noirs deviennent moites
que les mots deviennent sable que les
mots deviennent été chaleur lumière et
puis on passe à tanger tanger la ville
de la génération perdue
les écrivains des williams meuros des
musiciens des rolling stones
tu vois moi je suis allé à tanger ya et
à six mois et quand j'étais à l'hôtel el
minzah et bien j'ai senti cette espèce
d'extra ordinaire magie de tanger cette
espèce de places internationales
et justement par le biais de cette femme
de cette vieille [ __ ] et édenté tahar
ben jelloun nous restitue à la fois face
à la fois tanger
alors tu vois on voyage par les livres
on voyage dans la vie mais je vais te
dire les livres c'est le voyage le plus
fabuleux parce que tu voyages dans ton
for intérieur
bonsoir merci d'avoir passé cette soirée
avec lui au bar de la plage prochaine
ouverture samedi prochain salut bande de
nazes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est dans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
mais non tu mens
[Musique]
mais maintenant du monde ce n'est de ses
membres
[Musique]
le monde sur scène je disais à mon bébé
non crypté
[Musique]
mais non tu monde
je n'accepte crise
suivent ensuite
[Musique]
et
à
mais non
[Musique]
m
sachs est mon
[Musique]
et
tu mens
[Musique]
et
je n'ai accès montée
g
mais
[Musique]
au grand jeu physique ce bar de la plage
la question était de qui jean françois
michael at il été le chanteur et la
réponse
barbara
[Musique]
o o
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez gagné le thé les boucs philips
écran en 36 cm mise en veille
automatique est programmable
bravo
antenne 2 et philips vous ont présenté
le bar de la plage l'émission d'été de
thierry ardisson
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus